kylie jenner and boyfriend Tyga jet off  to sin city with Sun King Cairo tightly  packed her bags to join Tyga in las  vegas friday she instagrammed this shot  of her overnight luggage captioned  last-minute adventures three year old  king also fastened his seatbelt on the  private jet to support his dad and upon  landing made his way to the hotel room  the Rack City rapper had quite the  entourage for his performance at drais  nightclub however kylie reportedly did  not attend his concert since the venue  is strictly 21 and up I can perhaps the  19-year old reality star enjoyed room  service with Tyga's adorable toddler  Kylie may have missed the show but the  pair packs on the PDA when the rapper  was offstage it's an early  you